so what is [ __ ]
and how do we [ __ ] ourselves
technically speaking yeah frankfurt and
this is inspired by frankfurt and other
people's work uh based on frankfurt's
work on [ __ ] yeah classic essay
it's a pretty good title i think it's
one of the best things he wrote he wrote
a lot of good things the title or the
essay the essay okay
title's good too it's always an
icebreaker
in certain academic settings
so
let's contrast the [ __ ] artist from
the liar the liar
depends on your commitment to the truth
the [ __ ] artist is actually trying
to make you in-depth indifferent to the
question of truth and modify your
behavior
by making things salient to you so that
they are catchy to you
so
you know a prototypical example of
[ __ ]
is a commercial a television commercial
you watch these people
at a bar
getting some particular kind of alcohol
and they're gorgeous
and they're laughing and they're smiling
and they're clear-eyed
you know that's not true
and they know you know it's not true
but here's the point
you don't care
because there's gorgeous people
smiling and they're happy and that's
salient to you and that catches your
attention and so all you know
go into a bar you know that won't happen
when you drink
this alcohol you know it yeah but you
buy the product because it was made
salient to you
now you can't lie to yourself lex
salients can catch attention but
attention can drive salience so this is
what i can do
i can make something salient by paying
attention to it and then that will tend
to draw me back to it again
which
and you see what happens which means it
tends to catch my attention more
so that when i go into the store that
bottle of liquor catches my attention
and i buy it
and that's
why is that [ __ ]
because what you're doing is being
caught up
in the
salience of things
independent from whether or not that
salience is tracking reality
is it independent or is it loosely
connected because
it's not so obvious to me when i see
happy people at a bar
that i don't in part believe that
well my experience has been maybe
different
logically i can understand but maybe
there's a bar out there
where it's all happy people dancing
in fact most of the bars i go to these
days in texas there's pretty lots of
happy people
i think you can i mean
there's probably variation although i
think it's very the truth seeking in
there
let's say the intent is at least to try
and shut off your seeking it might not
completely succeed but that's the intent
at times it can completely succeed
because i can give you
pretty much gibberish
and never let it will motivate your
behavior there's a there's a
there's a episode from the classic
simpsons not the modern simpsons the
classic symptoms where the there's the
aliens and they're running for
office in the united states now i'm a
canadian so this doesn't quite work for
me but right and this speech goes like
this my fellow americans when i was
young i dreamt of being a baseball but
we must move forward not backward upward
not forward twirling twirling towards
freedom yeah and people go and there's a
rush yeah nothing there's nothing there
and yet it's great satire because a lot
of political speech is exactly like that
there's nothing there
you